these are fun if you had to get by the  way you know how hard it is for me not  have to do this  [Laughter]  trying to be i'm trying to be cool  if you had to get one movie quote  tattooed on your body what would it be  oh damn there's so many good ones oh god  there's so many i'd probably have to get  one a rocky quote the what what i'm  gonna have to go rocky quote but one of  my favorite movie scenes is when rocky's  telling um his son who was played by  milo and similar i think is rocky five  it was a sun life ain't no sunshine and  rainbows it will beat you down it will  hurt you and it's all about getting up  i'd have that whole though i have a  mural on my back  by talking to my kid i'll just go like  this